[Music]
colin kaepernick still doesn't have a
job in the nfl but he does have an ice
cream ben and jerry changed the world
w-h-i-r-l-e-d
uh plenty of companies out there
amazingly choosing to do business with
colin kaepernick when the nfl has chosen
to shun him now for nearly four years
but uh
now that half the people have turned off
the televisions let's have a
conversation with those who are still
here hello it's it's a pfd live on a
friday morning as we rock it toward the
finish line and we do so with our show
me something draft peter i have a
question for you
and this is a non
sports
non
politics non really pretty much of
anything question
according to the ben and jerry's website
what is the ideal temperature
for scooping and serving
ice cream a range is acceptable you
don't have to get the number right on
the head but give me a range uh for for
scooping and serving ice cream the ideal
temperature
26 to 30 degrees
uh
it's eight to ten eight to ten which let
me tell you wow eight to ten eight
unless you got
a a pretty damn good scoop
eight to ten is not the ideal scooping
range for me
uh
no i i mean
you you'd have to have the muscles of
cam hayward
yeah
uh i have bent many a spoon so i lost
you get to go first i i get to go first
uh but uh now we know what the ideal
temperature is according to ben jerry's
for uh scooping and serving ice cream
all right i'm buying time here as i pull
up my notes for this week's show me
something draft here we go i got to
start with jalen hurts why did i even
have to look at my notes this is your
chance be careful what you wish for
jaylen hertz you're a starting
quarterback in the nfl
against one of the best defenses in the
nfl so show me something show you
something show philly something show
everyone something because they are
craving
any sign of hope at the quarterback
position that maybe hurts is the guy and
peter you said he won't shy away from a
big stage it's a pretty big stage with
the saints defense coming to town
show me something james connor
so in the last couple of weeks james
connor marquis pouncey of the steelers
have been out
and i think now especially
with the urgency after the running backs
ran just
for just 21 yards
in the game against washington
this is an urgent
all hands on deck situation this week
when the steelers play at buffalo look
the bills know
that james connor benny snow mcfarland
they benny snell they know that these
guys are going to be aiming to fix the
running game so it's just going to be
mono imano
okay can you run the ball can you blow
the bills off the ball
it's essential not just for this week
mike
but for the steelers the rest of this
year
they need a running game james connor is
coming back
show me something james connor
absolutely great choice next one for me
and there are a bunch of good ones this
week andy dalton show me something
big red going back to cincinnati the
team that drafted you and
unceremoniously dumped you last year
you land in dallas as the back up to dak
prescott you're the starter now went
through a little coveted thing went
through a little concussion thing going
through a little bad football team thing
but not as bad as the bengals right now
the bengals without joe burrow and joe
mixon should be ripe for the plucking
this is andy dalton's chance to go back
to cincinnati and show them what he has
become at least for one afternoon in
december a year after he was released by
the team peter
show me something alex smith
okay this might be to some
a little bit cruel
but
all the wonderful stories about alex
smith have now been told i had him on my
podcast a beautiful you could have
played the the symphony music the
inspirational music
uh in the background of my conversation
with alex smith
he's the comeback player of the year if
he never plays another snap the rest of
his life they probably should give him
comeback player 2021 while we're at it
but
now is the time
not to say man it's great to have alex
back now is the time
for alex smith to win a very big game
and to forget all the wonderful stories
because
alex smith has to go to the place
that basically shunned him you know
drafted him in 2005. he was okay he had
some magical moments his incredible run
against the saints in the playoffs
behind joe staley no one can ever forget
those moments
but he's now two teams removed from
there he's now uh two years removed from
the worst injury that any of us has ever
seen a player come back from
so let's forget all that stuff
alex smith
you have to win a football game this
week
for your team to be in position to make
the playoffs
show me something you gallon alex smith
and remember how it ended for alex smith
in san francisco the old adage that you
don't lose your job due to injury
suffered a concussion during the 2012
season colin kaepernick came in then in
his second nfl campaign played well
enough that we never saw smith again and
they ended up in the super bowl and
after that super bowl smith was traded
the kansas city chiefs all right show me
something
mitchell trubisky this is your chance
even if only for once
no no no no no
look but all the time no shu listen he's
heard the talk for the last three years
that the bears took him instead of
patrick mahomes or desean watson at
least it's not the chiefs this week when
they have no chance of winning he gets a
chance to beat the team that has one of
the quarterbacks that constantly is
mentioned in chicago as a guy that the
bears should have taken instead of
trading up to get trubisky stay put
maybe even trade down a few spots and
get to sean watson so
this is it he could save a couple of
jobs maybe he could save his own this is
his chance this is his opportunity late
in the season everything's on the line
the bears are falling apart they scored
some points last week they just couldn't
hold it together near the end but this
is trubisky's chance again it won't it
won't be a permanent fix but at least
for one day he can vindicate what the
bears saw in him in the 2017 draft and
taking him over to sean watson peter
show me something derek carr
you know you've just taken taken your
team
it was only two three weeks ago mike
where derek carr
played
very well and played almost pass for
pass
until patrick mahomes
beat the the las vegas raiders late
but you know then he goes on the road
derrick carr does
and in the span of two games
on the east coast
in atlanta and at the new york jets
he and his teammates single-handedly
put gigantic question marks in every
corner of their organization
and look i i you know hey he made the
great throw late to henry ruggs
on by the way
a undrafted free agent cornerback in
single coverage with no safety help who
runs a 4540
and so you know let's let's not throw a
parade for the raiders for such a great
play at the end of this game they got a
lot of help
and so to me i think this is one of
those games
derek carr
you want to be out of john gruden's dog
house for the rest of your life these
are the games that you have to win these
games sunday against eight and four
indianapolis what i would call very
close to a must win for your team win
this game show me something derrick carr
show me something russell wilson after a
horrendous game against the giants and
colt mccoy the post-game press
conference there was almost
a cheerfulness from russell wilson after
losing that game there's been chatter
this week in seattle that he's got too
many other things going on that he's
distracted at one point pete carroll had
comments that were a lot like the bruce
aryan's passive aggressive shots at tom
brady this is time for russell wilson to
re-establish himself he doesn't have to
be an mvp candidate because that's over
but you have to establish yourself and
your team as legitimate playoff
contenders if he's anything short of
dominant against an overmatched jets
team
there is cause for concern about what
the seahawks can do in the post season
if they get there peter
you know i i can i do a just an
abbreviated show me something because i
gotta have two people on my last show me
something okay show me something cliff
kingsberry and kyler murray okay
this is a tough tough game against a
defense that has figured out how to
frustrate mobile quarterbacks
they wrote a book on it last week and
wrote you know in how to frustrate
russell wilson so this is the week
show me either do one of one of two
things
feature your running game
and have that running game come in and
try to bash the giants for four quarters
play differently do something we don't
expect
show me something schematically
cliff kingsbury show me something in
your game in lifting a team that's down
kyler murray show me something kingsbury
murray
yeah absolutely trying to avoid four
straight losses and we've seen the
blueprint gradually expand from the
seahawks to the patriots to most
recently the rams how to stop and slow
down and frustrate that offense and as
you said the giants they've shown they
can do it against a a better quarterback
a more accomplished quarterback at least
than kyler murray and russell wilson
last week so
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports